In this section, we're going to do some hands-on animating in Engine, and we'll start out by
diving right into Unreal Engine and walking through the creation of a simple animation
assembly in Sequencer using a few performance capture animation clips.
As we work through the animation assembly exercise, you can choose to follow along or
skip ahead to when you see the video jump back to the slides and review the steps used
for creating the animation assembly in Sequencer.
When starting out without a provided library of animation, you will need to import your
performance capture animations and then duplicate the original captured data.
Review the performances and duplicate the performances again for each clip you want
to create for your assembly.
Then edit and trim down the clips so that they are ready to use in your animation assembly.
So let's get started.
If you see where we left off, this is the animation assembly example that is already
inside the animation assembly folder with the folder for the animation clips.
Now rather than start out with something that's already done, let's go ahead and make this
ourselves.
So to do that, I'm going to go ahead and right-click in my content browser, move up to my cinematics,
and create a new level sequence.
I'm going to call this AnimAssembly EX, for example, and go ahead and hit Enter, then
double-click to open it on up.
From there, I'm going to need a mannequin to put into this level sequence.
For that, I'm going to go up to my outliner, select my SKMannequin TS example, and grab
this character and drag it into Sequencer.
Now if I look at this character, it pops in with the control rig on it.
Now I don't want to do that.
The control rig will override any animation and I need the animation to be what's driving
the control rig.
So before I get started with my animation clips, I'm going to go ahead and delete the
control rig.
Now I have a couple ways I can add in my animation.
I can either hit the plus button and choose from any animation in my list, or I can go
ahead and grab some animation clips from inside the AnimClips folder.
Now I'm going to start out with the Mani Walkup.
So I'm going to go ahead and drag this on in and I'm going to move this on over.
And this is a bit long for the walkup.
I'm going to keep this pretty short so we can add in more clips.
And I actually want a little bit more time, so let's move up into my viewport here and
you can see where this red 150 exists.
I'm going to go ahead and extend that to 300 frames.
Now at the bottom here in my timeline, you can see that it says 300 300.
There's no space on the end, but I need a little bit of buffer space just to see and
to give myself some room to see where the end of my animation actually is.
I'm going to change this to 330.
And I'm going to change this negative 15 to negative 30.
Now I have a little bit more space to work from and I want to see where we're going in
my animation.
So starting out here, you'll see that the animation is going all the way up to the walkup
and I can probably shorten this up a little bit.
So let's go to about frame 135 and let's go ahead and grab this blue mark here and just
drag this on over to 135.
From here, I'm going to move to about frame 60.
Yeah, about frame 60.
If I want to be exact, I can actually type in the number here that will take me exactly
to where I want to be.
So right at frame 60, I think this is a good cutting point.
If I'm on my animation and I right click, I can trim this by right clicking, going up
to edit and trim selection left.
That's going to give me a shorter animation clip.
I'm going to move this all the way down to the zero to start out here.
Now I'm going to need some more animation.
So let's go ahead and choose the head scratch or shrug.
Now it's up to you on which ones you want to use or what animation you want to work
with.
For me, I'm going to go ahead and choose the shrug.
So I'm going to start right here, right around 220.
I'm going to right click and I'm going to go ahead and edit and trim selection left.
Then I'm going to drag my shrug all the way down and with my shrug set, I'm going to go
ahead and go until the arms collapse and relax a little bit.
Right here at about 170.
From that, I'm going to go ahead and drag this on over so that this clip is 170 frames
total so far.
And then from here I need to add in some extra steps.
So from this position, I have a couple options.
Instead I'm going to start with a big giant sidestep.
Now this is a little bit long and it doesn't move quite where I want it to go because it's
on the opposite side, but we're going to fix that in just a little bit.
So before he starts to move, go ahead and put that right in here.
And I'm going to go ahead and right click, edit, trim selection left.
Move that on over and then let's choose some small sidesteps.
Now I'm not going to trim these down.
I'm just going to leave these where they are because I'm going to need some extra animation
at the end here to make sure that this all lines up.
But the first thing that we need to do is our bone matching.
So to start off, we're going to bone match the entire clip.
I'm going to go ahead and select everything.
And I'm going to go to animation, move up and blend first child of root.
That's going to blend them all together, but it's not going to do all of them.
So this is where bone matching comes into play.
For that, I'm going to go up and select the second clip in my timeline.
I can choose the first clip, but I'm going to choose my second clip.
I'm going to move from second clip to previous clip every time I match.
So this clip, I'm going to right click and go to match bone in the previous clip.
I'm going to choose my root.
Then I'm going to go ahead and choose my pelvis.
Same thing.
And I'm going to scrub through to see how they line up.
So they pop a little bit.
That's OK.
I want to match them again.
Let's go back up and match with the previous bone clip.
And let's choose now the foot.
So I'm going to choose part of the foot, which is going to be the ball on the left side.
You'll see him popping a place again.
And you see that gets us a little bit closer here.
Now I'm going to go through quickly and I'm going to go ahead and do the same thing with
my sidestep.
So if I look at my sidestep, you see it's way over there.
I'm going to go ahead and do the same thing.
Right clip, match with the previous clip.
I'm going to choose my pelvis.
And since this starts to move pretty quickly and I want my feet to match, I'm going to
go ahead and match this with bone in previous clip and choose my left foot again.
Ball left, right up in here.
And you can see that little pop in place.
That's kind of what I want.
Now it is still going to pop and we'll have to fix that.
There's some shifting that's probably on the root.
So let's go ahead and just make sure that we match up our end point in here.
So same thing here.
Right click, match bone with previous clip.
And let's go ahead and choose the pelvis first.
That gets us in place.
And let's see what happens first if we match the previous clip with the foot again.
So ball left.
And you can see that that's going to turn my character.
So unfortunately, that's not a good result.
I'm going to go ahead and choose this and let's match in here our bone with the previous
clip and just choose our pelvis again.
So this still lines up.
And since they're standing in almost the same position, it's going to be an okay clip for
blending.
Next is our blending options.
So we need to blend our animation tracks.
That's fairly easy.
So I'm just going to go ahead and hit the control button and drag across the top of
the timeline to zoom in on my blend sections.
And then I'm going to grab the next clip and smoosh that into the previous clip.
About 10 frames.
You can see I'm at 75.
Let's move that down to about 65.
That's going to give us a nice long blend between the two.
Now to modify my blend, I can right click directly on it, move up into my options and
choose some easing options.
For this one, I'm going to go ahead and choose a quartic in and out.
Now that's going to give us a fairly decent blend.
And I'm just going to move down my timeline to the next section, which will be easily
seen because now I have a gap between them.
So I'm just going to go ahead and drag that down and same thing, 160 to 150.
Let's just shove that right in, giving myself a good 10 frame blend between the two.
And in this one, I'm going to go ahead and right click on my options for my easing and
adjust this one to a cubic in.
But I'm blending from here into this a little bit faster towards the end.
That's probably going to help out a little bit in the blend itself.
Now I could probably make this the opposite direction.
So let's go ahead and change this, go right up in here, go to options and let's do a quartic
out.
And that'll be a little bit faster.
So we get down a little bit faster here.
I'm going to drag this on over.
We have a little bit of a bigger gap now.
And I actually have a subframe bleeding over in here.
So I'm going to clean this up just a little bit.
I'm going to grab my side step small and same thing.
I'm at 214.
I need enough space.
I'm going to go ahead and shove this down into 204.
And for this one, I'm going to keep this one pretty clean.
And you can see that this is my average option.
Rather than doing anything really different in here, I'm just go ahead and hit linear
and see what that looks like.
Yeah, so this is going to give me a pretty even change in here.
And that's going to work out just fine.
My feet slip a little bit, but that's okay.
I think I'll be able to fix that a little bit later.
Now I just want to drag all this out to the end.
And you can see that I have all this extra space.
If I move right to the end or type this in at 300, then I can right click, go into edit
and trim my section right.
That trims down my animation to fit within my timeline.
And that completes our animation assembly.
Now to make sure that my mannequin belongs to this level sequence, I'm going to go ahead
and right click it and convert this to a spawnable.
So now my level sequence is ready to have the inverse solved applied to it.
Okay, so let's jump back into our slides.
Okay, let's review everything we've just done inside Sequencer to create our animation
assembly.
The first step was placing the animated clips in the timeline.
We began by opening an animation assembly level sequence or creating a new animation
assembly level sequence to add our animation tracks to.
Then we chose any of the clips that were located in the Anim Clips folder.
Or if you used your own clips, we selected those and dragged them into the Sequencer
animation track to create our animation assembly.
We also deleted the control rig from the SK Mannequin actor inside Sequencer to prevent
that from getting in the way.
Next we applied bone matching.
And the first thing we did was right click on the animation track and check on the Blend
First Child of Root.
That blends the pelvis and was our first blending option to help match with all of our animations
based on their pelvis location.
Then to do more bone matching, we right clicked on the animation clip to bring up the clip's
properties.
We selected the Motion Blending option and matching the bone with either the previous
or next clip.
Then we selected the bone we wanted to use for matching.
We switched a little bit between the root, pelvis, and ankle just to see how those looked.
The third step was blending our animation tracks.
To do this, we grabbed the next track in our sequence and smooshed it into the previous
track.
This created a little blend between the two.
To modify the blend, we right clicked directly on the Blend option.
That brought up our Properties and Options menu and from there we moved into the options
for easing and selected our preferred easing option.
We played with a few options to see how those looked and then chose whichever one we preferred
for our desired animation easing.
Doing this completed our animation assembly.
And that's it for this section of our hands-on animating and engine.
I hope you enjoyed creating your animation assembly and in our next section we will continue
our hands-on animation and engine by using that assembly in our exercise Applying the
Inverse Solve.